if you're looking for ways to find your
passion push yourself and prove people
wrong then this video is for you think
that that you're a one-hit wonder or
whatever and just take that and you know
just make something that can prove
people wrong
picked up guitar your nose shred it on
that expert mode I had like the elbow
when you hit the thing with your elbow
and I felt super cool so I told my mom
give me a guitar and that's you know
from then that's where I really wanted
to make music who's to say that I can't
make a hip hop project and and make a
guitar song at the same time who's to
say that everybody's so close-minded
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation what's up it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from learning how to play guitar by
playing the video game Guitar Hero to
letting a major record deal and getting
number one on the US Billboard Hot 100
with his song rock star he's post Malone
and here's my take on his top ten rows
of success enjoy
rule number one just go for it
so why'd arson was actually pretty early
on but nobody wanted me to put out white
Iverson they just said wait wait like
wait unless I'll have time to wait I
don't have any money and I'll have
anything like what am I gonna lose you
know and then I made the album art their
original album art with the three and
Iverson was in the background and I put
it out the next day and then it just
went bananas
I put the song out butterflies in my
stomach went to bed woke up Wiz Khalifa
Mac Miller crazy plays everything like
that I said that I was freaking out like
I was going crazy i sat there next to
the computer and refreshed and refreshed
just to see all the views and google my
name and see what's happening and it was
literally like the cheesy like montage
movie come up scene
I got Lucky's you know and I loved
SoundCloud I think it's such a dope
medium for new artists who maybe don't
have the experience or any management or
any team just so you know put something
up and just see what happens
I knew it was gonna be big I didn't know
this fake rule number two
make it happen I just graduated high
school and then I did like half a
semester in of TCC and I didn't like it
so I just left and went to LA you know I
moved into a house with with my friend
from from Texas and you know he was
doing well and you know I kind of like
freeloader for a while you know I'm not
proud
but you know they gave me a room and
everything cuz I was working and they
really believed in what I was doing so I
had a room but everybody wanted the room
should be the studio I left my room and
then we built the studio in there I
moved into the closet upstairs I had an
air mattress and a mini-fridge and a
little clothesline thing I was folding
my jeans on the floor and shirts on the
rack rule number three keep pushing
yourself do you ever get a fear of I
don't have enough ideas do you ever
think to yourself but like what's the
next one right I mean you know I've
thought that way for a long time and so
did everybody else
who's like a one-hit wonder you know
whatever and then you know we put out
the new album and shout out to quavo and
Metro and we make congratulations and
you know that's bigger than white
Iverson has been and you know I guess
the next I guess you just got to keep on
pushing yourself to make think that that
you're a one-hit wonder or whatever and
just take that and you know just make
something that can prove people wrong
rule number four just be yourself
I was just funky I always loved like
penny loafers and ripped pants and in
high school I had my pants all the way
down here and I'd get in trouble all the
time and you know I won I went best
dressed in high school and most likely
to be famous in the high school kids at
school made fun of me but I'm all good
because now I'm in GQ at one point I was
just like I'm just gonna rock what I
like and if people don't like it yeah so
tell me why girl come on it's a cow
skull with two eagles but I was too
[ __ ] to finish the sides because I
heard like
rule number five find your passion I
just love music you know and I've always
had an appreciation and a love for music
but I didn't know that I wanted to do
music until you know guitar hero I
picked up guitar here and I'll shred it
on that expert mode I had like the elbow
when you hit the thing with your elbow
and I felt super cool so I told my mom
give me a guitar and that's you know
from then that's where I really wanted
to make music and keep writing my own
songs and express myself
I made on my own beats recorded on
audacity the free recorded program I did
it all myself I didn't Jason be quiet
I'm trying to record people in my school
loved it you know I mean cuz you know I
was really just trying to do what I
wanted to do and it was all really
supportive of that so I was like you
know everybody's telling me to do this
being supportive so I just want to take
it to the next level rule number six
figure things out for yourself I've
never been a confident singer so have
you ever had any singing classes or
anything like that has anyone ever tried
to not you hear they tried to make me do
it when I said no I'm just saying how I
sing I don't like the way she sings no
but you put it off though there's a
stylee to it you know I think I think
that's why you don't want to go to and
I'm not discouraging anybody from
learning more and taking classes or
anything but the reason why I never
wanted to take a class or take a guitar
lesson is because I really wanted to
figure it out myself and figure out how
I like to do it and what sounds good to
me because as much as people that people
will say why don't you take a class and
you know I don't want to sound like her
I want to sound like me I want to be
unique and they'll be like well she's
not gonna tell you to sing like her
she's just gonna help you get the best
out of your voice but you know what if
it sounds good to you then you know who
nobody can tell you nothing rule number
seven be happy from the beginning of my
career and then to where I am right now
it's just growing and getting bigger and
better and I'm getting better and
smarter and learning but you have to
continue you know and that's what makes
you I think that's what makes yourself
made is because at the end of the day
it's not gonna be about anybody else is
gonna be about yourself so if you're
happy with what you've done then you can
die happy you know what I mean rule
number eight prove people wrong who's to
say that I can't make a hip-hop project
and make a guitar song at the same time
who's to say that everybody's so
closed-minded amongst all this success
is always gonna be you know it's
definitely different coming into the
game as you know white guy then
everybody's like who the [ __ ] is this
dude Charlemagne picked on me and you
know it's whatever he don't like me if
you don't like it don't listen to it I
want to make great music I want to prove
people wrong I want to turn up I want to
show everybody what I'm about people
think I'm just taking advantage of
everything but I love this like this is
that I love this is what I want to do I
love the music I love making music I
love the people that I'm around I love
my friends and my family and all the
people that really stood by me whenever
I took the leap to do what I wanted to
do and you know no one can really say
rule number nine get a good team advice
for new artists
what kind of business advice can you
give to new artists I mean business-wise
get a good team get a team that's not
gonna come around and make it trouble
get a team that's gonna look out for you
you know that let's take care of you cuz
I think I I think I'm the smartest
person alive I'm the smartest person
that I've ever met but sometimes my
decisions aren't very smart so
business-wise just pick a good team a
good manager a good engineer get
everything good and get your sound right
and just keep on truckin rockin rollin
rule number ten have fun
everyone
little babies herein lies my mama garcy
or TV since it the chain
taken right away
[Music]
in case of
now we made
so what I really liked about him was
he's always himself whether it's from
his voice to the way he wears his hair
to his clothes to his songs he's himself
you take it or leave it
and he goes all-in on that and I think
entrepreneurs in general could use a lot
more of that self belief there's the one
word self belief in yourself to go off
and do the thing you want to do and not
everybody didn't like it and that's okay
in terms of the rules I'm gonna go with
the rule number two is my personal
favorite that make it happen where he
was living in somebody's house and they
wanted to turn that into a studio and he
said yeah let's do it and so he moved
into the closet I think people tend to
think they don't have the resources they
don't have the studio they don't have
the money they don't have the equipment
they don't have the gear they don't have
the team they don't have the XYZ to the
gloss and do it well here this guy
didn't even have a home and he lajas the
only room he had so you can get his
recording studio up and get his dream
off the ground so he would live in a
closet to make that happen and so what
are you willing to sacrifice to go off
and get your dream the ultimate resource
is gonna be your resourcefulness it's
never about how many resources you have
it's about how resourceful you will be
to make your dreams of reality and so
rule number two is my personal favorite
I love to know from you guys do you
agree with me was rule number two the
best one or is the one that you like
more leave it down the comments below
I'm really excited to see what you have
to say
now I made this video because Felipe
Ortega asked me to if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next check out the link in the
description and you can go and cast your
vote on the request line I also want to
give a quick shout out to David from
soup TV David thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and posting about it on Twitter I
really appreciate it man and I'm so glad
you enjoyed the book so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
[Music]
everybody still thinks I'm an industry
plant cuz I just happened so fast like
where the hell did he come from what
happened and you know everybody thinks
that you gotta sell your soul or do some
mysterious actor or so they did right I
haven't - oh no I just wanna know what
happened every label that came at me you
know and I just felt like you have to
wait and hold out to see what you really
want and what really works for you and
if the vibe is right and the people are
right I think you you know automatically
and you know when Republic came on me
and I met Tyler and everybody over there
I think I just knew automatically so
that's where I wanted to go
people don't want you to succeed do you
feel that yeah everywhere it's
everywhere in every aspect do you get
motivated by that ya know if you don't
like me that's cool I got hella people
that do yeah and they love me and I love
them and they're gonna take me and then
we're gonna just the most important work
ever if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you Apple that would be to like a
little beacon hey believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]